Viola Davis has had some pretty steamy  sex scenes on how to get away with  murder  but now she's telling Ellen DeGeneres  she's it done with them I told them no  more sex scenes  you cannot football fixings but you  cannot throw me up against the wall  they threw me up against the wall the  first season and I threw my back out for  two weeks and my kid yeah  so I limped around for two weeks and I  said no more walls I just want to you  know be on the bed and I don't want to  move I don't want anyone on top of me I  don't want to be on top of anybody else  as for what we can't expect from the new  season of the ABC hit here's what Biola  teased et with last month you can expect  a huge mystery and it's going to be  presented in a very personal Pepa sewed  a lot of things are gonna be solved and  sewn up in this whole season but the  mystery that is going to be presented is  enormous  you